In this lesson, we're going to take a look at lighting tools
and we're going to interactively light a hero object.
Feel free to follow along for this part of the lesson.
So let's get started.
So for this lesson, I went and opened up here a VST.
There is a hero end, which is a simple example
of what you can do to get your lighting
in the right direction.
But we're going to go ahead and build our own.
Now you'll see a few things in here
if you have some lights floating around,
go and just kill them.
I might have my sky in here still,
just a few little things in here.
So feel free to remove them completely.
And what we also want to do,
and you'll notice the difference in mind
is I have a glowing material.
So I'm just going to briefly talk about that for a second.
I simply just grabbed the material for the windshield.
So if I select the object itself,
you will see the windshield material in here
under details, let's go back up.
There we go, went too far.
And you'll see it's element three.
That element three, I simply just went in here
and connected that color to the emissive right there.
And then I just hit save or apply.
Apply it to see if you like it,
save if you want to keep it.
So let's go ahead and get started here
and actually remove a few more things.
I'm going to get rid of my volumetric cloud.
I'm going to hit delete on that.
I'm going to get rid of my skylight.
I'm going to get rid of my directional light
as well as my exponential light fog.
So we're going to use that tool we used earlier on.
I'm going to go to windows
and I'm going to go to my environment light mixer.
In here, I can quickly get up and running
by clicking on my create skylight,
create atmospheric light,
create a volumetric cloud and create a high fog.
You might get an error at first
because there are some dependencies
and it will tell you on real say,
hey man, I need the environment in here
and you don't have it yet.
Just go ahead and keep clicking
and you should get those in the right direction.
Now, if you ever needed another directional light,
let's say I created another directional light
and I drag it on the scene.
Unreal is going to say like, man, what are you doing?
I don't understand.
Which one do you want to affect the fog?
In that case, you want to go ahead
and in that directional light,
just type in forward shading
and then change the priority order.
And you can do that with either directional light
and that will solve that issue.
So let's go ahead in our directional light
that we have in here already.
Let me move some of these around
just to sort between them.
There you go.
We're going to lower this directional light
to a very low angle.
Now, the nice thing about this reacting to our environment,
if I wanted more red light,
I can make it look like a sunset
or if I want to just pitch black dark, I can,
or maybe I just want to pull in some of that cool light.
So to do that, I can just make it a little bit higher
and in here, just slightly orange with the light.
In here, I can just lower my amount
to maybe make it 0.5.
There you go.
And even lower, we can do 0.2.
So most of our light is dependent upon what we throw in
after the fact, such as creating a key light,
fill light and back lights
and any rim lighting that we want to add.
So we have that up and running.
We also want to make sure we're using Lumen.
So always check your scene when you can
and that requires going into your project settings.
And like we mentioned before, going under rendering
and you want to make sure that Lumen is on.
And we have Lumen here set for global dynamic method.
We also have reflections Lumen.
We're also looking at our ray lighting mode.
I'm setting it kind of high
for our hit lighting for reflections.
And then I'm also setting my software ray tracing mode
to detail tracing.
To do that though, you want to make sure
you're using hardware ray tracing when available.
And also with that, you want to make sure
that you also have supports hardware ray tracing overall.
This is going to be very helpful to work with your scene
because Unreal's Lumen does borrow some of that tech.
Now you can use it without these fallbacks
but you're not going to get as efficient workflows
and you're not going to get the precise stuff
that you would get borrowing
some of that ray tracing technology.
And you really want to try to work
with a graphics card that has it.
Again, virtual shadow maps are on by default
and also make sure in your scenes
especially if you're getting it from the marketplace
make sure that you have SM6 active.
This is going to support your virtual shadows
but mainly also going to support your visualizers
for them to even come up, such as looking
through your Nanite and your virtual shadow map visualizer.
So I'm going to close this out
just some things to remember.
And now we need a post-process volume.
So I'm going to go down
and go to my quickly add to project.
I'm going to go to my volumes.
I'm going to go to that post-process volume.
You can also type it in into get context.
So I can type in post-process volume.
You'll see it right there.
You also want to make sure
let's do the tick boxes here real quick.
We want to make sure they're infinite extended bound.
It's got a little bit kind of almost
towards the middle and turn that on.
We want to make sure that we're running completely
with Lumen.
So turn on your reflections for Lumen
and turn on your global elimination for Lumen.
From there, we can turn on these for quality control.
Now I'm not going to crank these too high.
We'll leave them by default.
I think you get the idea of how to adjust these.
So don't, we need to spend a lot of time fussing
with our settings.
That's something that you can do to get your image
and your scene exactly the way that you want.
I'm also going to turn on my Lumen reflections
and I'm going to turn on the hit aligning for reflections.
Get us our highest quality.
Don't have to worry too much about translucency.
There's really isn't anything translucent here.
And then we'll have a max reflection bounces.
So if you want to, we can increase that to maybe two
or three, if you want.
We'll do three in this case.
So you'll see a bit of noise going on
in our scene initially.
And that's because some of these glowing objects
such as these small ones over here, like in this angle
you'll see a lot of noise.
You don't see as much noise here,
but you see a lot of it here
because that's a small glowing object
and a real kind of has a little bit of problem with that.
Now, if we wanted to, we can go and replace
that material to prevent that
and replace that material for that object
or even change the material of the vehicle
and edit it in some way where there's less roughness.
We can all do that.
And we talked about that before previously.
We can also in our post-process volume
just a little quick nugget.
We can also control our exposure.
Now this is covered in other classes,
but I'll briefly talk about it.
I'm going to leave on auto exposure.
With that auto exposure,
I'll turn on my minimum and my maximum.
You'll see the auto exposure adjust itself.
And we're going to lock that down to a one and a one.
And that's a good place to work from there.
And that's just a quick rundown with that.
If you want to adjust it more,
there's a exposure compensation
and I can adjust a slider to what I need.
I can leave it by default.
That way we're pushing more stuff through the light.
So now let's go ahead and pull in a Rec Light.
There's a Rec Light.
One thing I want to mention with the Rec Light,
you want to make sure that you're not pushing
your Rec Lights through geometry.
You will get noise when it comes to ray tracing.
And there is a little bit of noise that may peak in
when using a Rec Light in a Lumen scenario,
because it's using some of that information.
It's using those photons,
calculating and then bouncing it back to the camera.
So try not to shove them into geometry.
It also doesn't make too much sense to do so,
because you will get a hard line anyway.
Want to make sure this light is movable.
And then from there, we don't want to control.
We want to control our source width and our source height.
Let's go and move this up.
And we can also angle this if we need to.
And I can move it back just a little bit.
There we go.
A little mood lighting for that.
Pretty nice.
Let's go ahead and pull in a Fill Light here.
Now the Fill Light is going to be another Rec Light.
So we'll pull that in,
pull it off to the side, a little moodiness going on.
We'll do a 90 degree angle again.
Move that over.
Move that up.
Ooh, nice.
Little subtle.
Move that over here just a little bit more.
Turn off the cast shadows.
Set that to movable.
Very important,
because it's going to update for us correctly with the GI.
We're going to control the width
and we're going to control the height.
Now you'll notice the shape is showing up.
See that?
Kind of don't want that.
So to be able to dumb that down, you can use Spec.
We can go into the Spec and lower that.
Now you're going to lose some of those little shiny bits,
but we don't really have a lot using this light.
So we're okay.
We're not using this for rim lighting.
So we don't have to worry about that too much.
I'm going to move this over.
I'm going to rotate it
and I'm going to give it a different color.
Let's have some fun.
So I'm going to go in here
and make this kind of like almost a purple.
Little cyberpunk looking.
Purplish pink, I guess you could say.
And you can also pluck that color.
And what I mean by that is clicking on the color wheel,
you can actually use a dropper
and you can choose what color you want.
So I'm going to make it a little bit stronger.
Have some fun with that.
And then now let's go ahead and make some rim lighting.
Now the rim lighting, if we're using a Rec light,
we got to be careful
because it may not quite be exactly
the way they want to tackle it.
And what I mean by that
is that shape could still give us some trouble.
What we could do is dumb down the reflectivity
on anything nearby to prevent it.
Or again, like we did, control the spec.
So let's go ahead and pull that Rec light in.
Let's go ahead and move this back.
Rotate this light.
We'll do a 180.
Move this up in the air.
And then now I'm going to control the source width.
And I'm going to control the source height.
And I'm going to rotate this towards our vehicle.
And I want to put it a little bit closer.
This is a pretty cool shot right there.
Almost looks like a showroom.
Kind of a moody looking showroom.
And now let's actually make this a lot more thin.
I use this a lot in Love, Death and Robots.
Thought this was a really great light to work with.
Quickly got myself some rim lighting if I needed it.
Look at that, nice little sliver of light.
You can move it in closer if you want to
get that moodiness.
Now, if we remove the spec,
we could run into some trouble.
So let's move this back just a little bit to hide that.
Oh, there we go, we're cheating.
Letting that reflection kind of mask that shape.
If I want to, I can increase the height a little bit there
and then move this in a little bit this way.
So we can do a little bit of cheating.
Now we can do it this way
and I'll increase the strength just a little bit.
Not too much.
And we can angle it to hide that shape too.
Now again, we can do the spec
but I don't really want to lose my spec.
So if I move this in a little bit closer
and move it back
and then just rotate this just a bit
and control the height.
And then now it's like for moving furniture, right?
This is how it is when you play with lights.
We want to push it right towards the edge of that vehicle.
It's probably too strong right now.
And at a certain angle,
you'll notice we can ditch that shape.
That's a little bit strong.
So we'll lower that
and then we'll move it over a little bit
and we can lower it
or raise it up any way that we want.
Now I'm hiding it within the reflection
based on my camera positioning.
Sneaky, sneaky, sneaky.
All right.
And you can make that any color that you need and want.
And we can even increase our fill light here
just a little bit brighter here
to what we want, what we're going for.
We'll make that, let's make that about 12.
I think that works.
Now, if you want to, we can bring in a spotlight here,
move them over here.
This could be a little bit of fill.
We can adjust your cone angle
and use it almost like partially using some rim lighting.
So the cone angle, let's adjust that.
So we have the inner and the outer.
So let's mainly do the outer here.
We can do a little more focal area.
And then if we want to make that light
at the edge of my screen there,
make that also a different color.
We can choose what we want it to be.
I'll choose green in this case.
Why not?
It's like cyberpunk land, right?
Our world, everybody's paying rent.
And then you can dumb down things accordingly.
So like, hey, you know what?
This is great, but I'm going to make this half the amount
so you can make that a six, ooh, a little more moody.
And then we can put a point light in here.
And again, make sure these new lights you bring in
are movable.
This is going to give us our updates.
And this new point light, make it movable,
move it right underneath here.
And we're going to cheat.
We're going to grab that light
and we're going to use a dropper
and that dropper is going to give us a color we want.
I can change that color if I want to
and give it a little more saturation.
There we go.
Look at that little cyberpunk moodiness there.
And again, we can blow these out
as much as we need to or want to.
It's up to us.
Now, again, be careful of that shape.
If it sneaks in, just angle your camera
because we have not developed it yet
where you can actually turn that shape off
like you would in 3D Studio Max and other programs.
But right now you can see,
hey, that looks pretty good if I hit the G key.
Here's my little vehicle.
If I want to, I can even highlight a little more light here.
And, but I think you get the idea
of how you can get things in the right direction.
And again, watch out for those shapes
that may show up in the reflection.
But overall, that's about it with this one.
And let me hit the G key here
and you can see all the lights in play.
And again, you can open things up any way that you want.
We'll open up that cone angle
and then just blast this a little bit more with the green.
Ooh, there we go.
Ending on a good note.
Very cyberpunk.
And then hit the G key here.